what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu and today we're
back with more major x-men news now at
this point in time in the marvel
cinematic universe it really does seem
like kevin feige and the people over at
marvel studios have cast some pretty big
names to play some pretty big x-men
characters already and if we are going
to get some sort of a x-men slash mutant
announcement at disney's d23 event
coming up in just about a month now it
would make sense that we already have a
cast or at least some of the cast and
the lead actors for an x-men movie and
we get more and more evidence each week
that points to the fact that marvel has
already cast some x-men characters and
today we have even more evidence as
young carlos esposito has come out and
publicly stated that he has spoken to
marvel studios he has had talks with him
about playing a character in the mcu and
he actually goes on to address the
rumors of everybody fan casting him as
people like doctor doom magneto and even
professor x and he even says that he
would love to play professor x check out
the clip here
there's the talk of magneto
here's the talk of dr freeze
there has been talk of who else are they
talking about over there
and there is
professor x
pick one pick one
i'm gonna go for something that is a
little bit different
i'm gonna go
and put it out in the universe that it
is
professor x
this clip was posted by countdown city
geeks on tick tock so props to them
awesome video and what's really
interesting about this video is that
giancarlo esposito seems to be kind of
going against how everybody else that
marvel is it's obviously very known that
marvel is very private and very
secretive and they have really tight
security and typically the actors who
meet with marvel studios don't really
say much but this is actually refreshing
and pretty awesome because giancarlo
esposito says that he has met with
marvel studios in the beginning he talks
about meeting with marvel he says i have
met with marvel they've had some
conversations he talks about some other
stuff real quick and then he comes back
to kind of address all of the fan
castings that the fans have put out
there and here's the thing i actually
think that he could be playing one of
these roles that he's kind of joking
about with the exception of dr freeze i
find that very funny he says dr freeze
and i'm assuming he means mr freeze
which is also really funny because
that's dc now maybe he's been talking to
warner brothers and dc studios about
playing mr freeze for the dc universe
and i don't think that he has a problem
distinguishing between dc and marvel i
think right here he's just simply saying
all of the things that people have fan
cast him as he's a really really smart
guy so i doubt he's mixing up franchises
here i think he's simply listing all of
these fan castings and potential roles
now of course the other real ones that
could happen in the mcu are as he
mentions magneto doctor doom and
professor x and quite honestly he could
play any of these roles and pretty much
crush it i think now we have fan art of
him in all of these different roles and
all of these different characters and
each role he looks pretty dang good like
he fits the part but let's talk about
what we could realistically expect one
let's confirm he has met with marvel
studios he states that and i'm assuming
there's a good chance that it is for an
x-men character recently it has been
revealed that marvel studios has been
meeting with actors about x-men roles
taryn egerton even confirmed that he met
with marvel studios four years ago to
talk about playing cyclops he confirmed
this on the serious xm show sway in the
morning and big shout out to sway for
sending me that so it looks like marvel
has been looking out for who they want
to play certain members of the x-men for
a very long time and it looks like they
are eyeing giancarlo esposito as well
now marvel studios has a tendency to
meet with actors many times about many
different roles until they find that
perfect role many of you know that this
is what happened with jake gyllenhaal
marvel studios met with him many many
times about a bunch of different roles
until they finally found mysterio and
went that's it that's the role that's
who you're gonna play but the reason
that i think giancarlo esposito is going
to be playing an x-men is one well
because he wants to and two is because
well there are now a ton of different
new characters coming in the form of
x-men mutants we're gonna get a ton of
mutants in the mcu not just four or five
heck we already have one kamala khan and
namor is coming in black panther wakanda
forever and since he does have the wings
on his feet it does look like they are
going to keep his half mutant origin as
well so i truly do think we are about to
see a lot of different mutants in the
mcu and the actual x-men team which i
think could have already been cast and
like i said i think giancarlo esposito
is going to be playing one of these
three characters professor x magneto or
doctor doom and if he is playing doctor
doom we could even see him as early on
as wakanda forever possibly in a post
credit scene we'll talk more about this
in just a bit but first thank you to
manscape for sponsoring this video many
of you have probably heard me talk about
manscape before big fan of their
products and the confidence that comes
with being properly groomed you seem to
have a better aura a better vibe you
just kind of carry yourself better
manscaped has always been the leader in
below the waist grooming but now with
the platinum package 4.0 you can trust
manscaped with a lot more in the
platinum package 4.0 you'll find your
normal awesome manscape products like
the lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer and the
weed whacker nose and ear hair trimmer
featuring the proprietary advanced skin
safe technology so where you don't nick
your skin both of which are also
waterproof you also get the crop
preserver anti-chafing ball deodorant
the crop reviver ball spray toner and
they even throw in two free gifts
anti-chafing boxers and the shed travel
bag get 20 off and free shipping with
the code cosmic manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use code cosmic to get all you need
to unlock your big groomed energy now as
far as the post credit scene for black
panther wakanda forever goes there's a
big rumor going around right now that we
could see dr doom keep in mind this is
not confirmed in any way shape or form
however i do think it makes sense if you
follow the do-more storyline and i've
been talking about this i think for over
two years now the fact that dr doom
would want vibranium from wakanda or
perhaps in the ocean where atlantis is
now doctor doom is a genius so perhaps
he knows that he's never gonna be able
to get vibranium from the ocean as long
as the atlanteans and namor are there we
do see a few scenes in black panther
wakanda forever where some soldiers kind
of board some boats and ships these
could be dr doomsmen or the people on
the ships could be dr doom's people and
the people boarding them are trying to
shut them down so doctor doom kind of
pitting wakanda and atlantis against
each other so they can both kind of be
in peril and perhaps both of their
cities kind of destroyed would be the
perfect opportunity for him to come in
and take some vibranium for himself so
if giancarlo esposito is playing doctor
doom then we could be seeing him in
november and i actually think doom might
be the role we do actually see him in
now i would love to see him play
professor x but i still do believe that
he has to follow some of marvel's rules
and remember marvel really kind of tells
you what to say and what you can't say
which is why i think him saying that he
wants to play professor x could be a big
intentional misdirect he's already met
with marvel studios so the fact that
he's saying i want to play professor x
is awesome but is kind of sketchy he a
little suss if he was in talks to play
professor x i doubt he would be able to
say that but at the same time he
mentioned a bunch of other roles as well
so perhaps he feels like he's being
vague enough about it that it's okay but
i think that just his demeanor the way
that he presents himself and carries
himself is very doctor doom which is why
i think he would be best fit for that
however he would make a great magneto as
well he'd make a great professor x2 but
i think that's kind of a misdirect like
i mentioned before however going back to
him probably playing doom if he's
already met with marvel studios doom is
going to be coming before the x-men come
and we're not really sure when they are
going to introduce magneto in the mcu
even if they introduce mutants and have
a whole x-men movie that doesn't
necessarily confirm magneto is going to
be the villain of that movie now if they
do origins i would hope they would do
magneto but also if they are going to do
somewhat origins the characters might be
younger than we're used to it might kind
of be like x-men first class so they'd
probably want an actor younger than john
carlo to play those roles so i think
doom is very well suited for him
especially if we consider the timeline
of when doom should appear compared to
the x-men but these are just my thoughts
let me know what you think about this in
the comments down below who do you think
he should play in the mcu let me know
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe for more awesome
marvel content for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you